bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous
confier une recette pour améliorer la
condition humaine sur la planète et en
même temps une recette de cuisine à base
de pommes de terre
il faut que je vous avoue dans la vie je
suis chef de cuisine le jardin gourmand
à lorient depuis 25 ans
j'ai eu la chance d'écrire des livres de
cuisine qui ont reçu quelques
récompenses internationales et je donne
des cours de cuisine
tout ça pour vous dire que les recettes
c'est plutôt mon dada
je vais commencer par vous expliquer le
premier ingrédient de mars est pour
améliorer la condition humaine sur la
planète
pour ça il faut que tu remontes quelques
années en arrière
j'ai 16 ans je suis en pleine crise
d'adolescence
je trouve le monde complètement injuste
une partie de la planète qui meurent de
faim et notre partie de la planète la
nôtre atteinte de malbouffe
c'était le titre de mon livre de chevet
de 16 à 18 ans qui nourrit son bétail
avec l'agriculture des pays pauvres qui
meurent de faim quand on est jeune on a
des idées et on a les moyens de ses
idées je décide donc d'arrêter de me
goinfrer du bétail et des laitages et de
me nourrir exclusivement de légumes et
de céréales produit du côté de chez nous
si ce régime n'avait été que végétarien
c'était pas grave c'était même plutôt
bien je pense mais voilà comme beaucoup
de jeunes filles je me trouve trop
grosse et je décide de moins manger et
petit à petit je tombe dans une crise
d'anorexie qui va facilement durer deux
ans je réussi quand même à obtenir mon
bac mathématiques et surtout à pouvoir
choisir une orientation
si je veux rester fidèle à mes idées il
faut que j'apprenne
ah bien cuisiner les légumes pour bien
me nourrir convaincre mes amis ma
famille à bien se nourrir et qu'ensemble
nous puissions résoudre les problèmes de
faim dans le monde
donc je décide de m'orienter vers un
lycée hôtelier mes voiles
imaginez-vous il y a trente ans une
jeune fille timide
m sérieuse et surtout bon élève qui
décide de faire juste des études dites
juste manuel pour certains de mes
professeurs ces mêmes professeurs qui
pensaient que ces études juste manuel
n'était bonne que pour des grand
gaillard costaud et surtout plutôt
mauvais élèves bien voilà moi j'avais
des parents qui s'intéressait à mes
idées alors je les faisais je leur ai
fait peur avec ma crise d'anorexie
mais s'intéresser à mes idées il
adhérait à mes idées d'ailleurs il bouge
beaucoup plus de légumes depuis ce temps
là et donc ils m'ont encouragée à
poursuivre mes études vers un lycée
hôtelier
alors le premier ingrédient de mars est
pour améliorer la condition humaine sur
la planète c'est la confiance
et si je reviens à ma recette de cuisine
ma purée de pommes de terre en fait ça
va être une purée de pommes de terre je
vais vous expliquer la confiance dans ma
purée de pommes de terre c'est la
variété de la pomme de terre
je vous explique si vous utilisez une
pomme de terre à chair tendre et non à
chair ferme votre pomme de terre à
s'écraser facilement va absorber
facilement le lait la crème ou le beurre
ainsi la recette va être facile tout va
se faire beaucoup plus facilement et
bien voilà ma pomme de terre s'adapte à
ma purée
mes parents se sont adaptés à mes idées
la pomme de terre faciliter l'exécution
de la purée et bien pareil la confiance
en soi la confiance envers les autres je
pense facilite drôlement la vie
je vais passer au deuxième ingrédient
pour améliorer la condition humaine sur
la planète
je rentre au lycée hôtelier et là je
vais rencontrer le producteur de mon
deuxième ingrédient c'est arnaud c'est
mon futur mari
il tombe littéralement amoureux
l'anorexie il ne l'a pas vu l'amour rend
aveugle
nous faisions les mêmes études arnaud
était en colocation et moi j'étais seul
dans mon appartement dont car nous
venaient dîner tous les soirs chez moi
dans mon appartement
mais voilà quand on est anorexique n'est
très organisé on maîtrise tout et la
gestion du mon frigo
elle était plus que maîtrisé arnaud
arrivé le premier soir de la semaine
dans mon appartement
ouvrez vos frigos et me dévalisaient mon
frigo de la semaine en une soirée
alors j'aurais pu m'énerver j'aurais pu
tout arrêter j'aurais pu mettre arnaud
dehors mais voilà je suis tombée
amoureuse et grâce à l'amour simple
d'arnaud petit à petit j'ai re croquer
la vie à pleines dents
j'ai oublié mon anorexie donc le
deuxième ingrédient pour améliorer la
condition humaine sur la planète c'est
l'amour est dans ma purée de pommes de
terre
l'amour c'est le lait la crème et le
beurre que vous allez incorporé à votre
chère de pommes de terre
si vous en incorporer trop votre purée
va être indigeste grâce voir un peu
liquide
si vous n'êtes encore pourrait pas à ses
potes curé va être fade sèche manqué un
peu de saveur bien voilà le lait la
crème et le beurre à même de la saveur
un équilibre à la purée de pommes de
terre bien je pense que dans la vie
l'amour pareil parler de la saveur et va
nous rendre plus équilibrée
je vais passer à mon troisième
ingrédient pour améliorer la condition
humaine sur la planète
je suis en fin d'études hôtelière et en
fin d'études hôtelière on a l'obligation
d'effectuer un stage non pas un stage de
cuisine ni un stage de serbie
c'est un stage de gestion alors je me
retrouve à travailler dans une cafétéria
commercial et a passé par tous les
postes le but de cette entreprise
c'était de vendre un produit alimentaire
qui pour moi n'a aucune âme
je suis une jeune fille sérieuse
consciencieuse j'exécute les arbres mais
sans trop de fourie la directrice de
l'époque s'en aperçoit c'était facile
arrive le bilan de stage
nathalie tu n'es vraiment mais vraiment
pas faite pour ce métier là arrête les
métiers de la restauration change de
voie alors heureusement j'étais
amoureuse je n'étais plus anorexique
donc j'étais plutôt bien dans mes
baskets et je suis une personne qui
n'est pas spécialement influençable donc
voilà le troisième ingrédient pour
améliorer la condition humaine
c'est la force de caractère et dans ma
purée de pommes de terre la force de
caractère
c'est la solution que vous allez trouver
si vous ratez votre purée de pommes de
terre
je vous explique si vous allez trop vos
pommes de terre automatiquement votre
purée de pommes de terre va être aux
deux salles deux solutions soit vous
jetez tout ou alors à la rigueur vous la
mangez mais sans plaisir puis c'est pas
très bon pour la santé
ou alors vous trouver une solution pour
améliorer votre purée de pommes de terre
trop salie et ça c'est la solution alors
c'est une purée de pommes de terre dans
laquelle j'ai ajouté une bouillie de
sarrasin est là comme ma purée de pommes
de terre est trop salée najjar ajoute
une bouillie de sarrasin qui n'est pas
sali et au résultat final ça va me faire
une purée de pommes de terre et sarrazin
qui fait merveille avec une belle salade
verte mais aussi surtout pour mon mari
une pièce de viande rouge
c'est un délice donc voilà je vais
passer à mon quatrième agréé dia pour
améliorer la condition humaine sur la
planète
alors vous vous rappelez mes trois
premiers ingrédients c'était la
confiance
ce l'amour la force de caractère et je
pense qu'ils sont importants et
peut-être pas primordiaux le quatrième
il va être primordiale j'ai fini mes
études et je vais enfin pouvoir rentrer
dans la vie active continuer à apprendre
mon métier dans des grands restaurants
et là j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
travailler pendant quatre ans dans trois
grands restaurants parisiens tenus par
trois grands chefs passionnés par leur
métier et qui en plus d'être passionné
savait transmettre leur savoir faire
et puis un jour j'ai décidé de
m'installer de créer mon restaurant avec
mon mari est donc il a fallu j'annonce
mon départ et j'ai annoncé mon départ à
alain dutournier
donc c'est tellement dernier restaurant
alain dutournier possède le carré des
feuillants à paris c'est un restaurant
qu'à deux étoiles au michelin
c'est un restaurant qui est à dire
mondialement connu il cite un chef qui
est toujours très occupé
et quand je lui ai annoncé mon départ il
me propose quand même de m'accorder une
après midi pour discuter de mon futur
projet alors bien sûr j'accepte arrive
cette fameuse après midi je suis un
petit peu stressé j'arrive avec la
future carte des mets on s'assoit une
poser question puis rapidement je
comprends que ma carte des mets ne
l'emballent pas vraiment écouté nathalie
j'ai l'impression je ne ressens rien en
fait dans tes mais je ressens pas du
tout à personnalité j'ai l'impression
peut-être pour me faire plaisir que tu
as essayé de l'imiter mais franchement
tu mama limité alors vous savez je vous
ai déjà dit j'étais un peu stressé mais
là j'avais les lames qui commençait à
monter aux yeux ils sont la paire soir
il le ressent c'est quelqu'un qui est
très sensible donc il construit et là il
va me poser une question qui va être
déterminant pour le restant de ma
carrière
simple il me dit nathalie quand tu
rentres en bretagne chez toi tu adore
cuisiner
alors qu'est-ce que tu cuisines à tes
amis à ta famille
et là je peux vous dire j'étais en
larmes
je réponds avec mon coeur mes tripes 8i
une souche et j'ai cru vraiment qu'il
allait sauter au plafond
ma proposition n'allait pas du tout huit
l'air eh bien non grand sourire
il me dit mais c'est ça la solution
cuisine ce que tu aimes et tu verras les
clients l'aimeront en plus du sceqe
l'usiné tu aimes tu as région y aura
aucun souci
donc voilà le quatrième ingrédients pour
améliorer la condition humaine
primordial c'est la transmission la
transmission du savoir faire bien sûr
mais aussi la transmission
intellectuelle nous apprendre à
réfléchir dans le bon sens et je reviens
à ma recette de pommes de terre
la transmission est bien elle est aussi
indispensable parce que c'est le geste
je vous explique si en incorporant le
lait la crème le beurre dans votre chair
de pommes de terre vous l'incorporer
avec un fouet la mouvement très
énergique bien vous allez rendre pâteuse
élastique votre purée de pommes de terre
alors que si vous l'incorporer
délicatement en souvent votre purée à
l'aide d'une spatule
vous allez obtenir une pomme de terre en
purée de pommes de terre légère willows
donc voilà et j'arrive enfin à mon
dernier ingrédient pour améliorer la
condition humaine sur la planète
je vous ai dit de la transmission était
primordiale le cinquième c'est
indispensable
je vais enfin pouvoir créer mon
restaurant
allez mon mari selon notre idéal selon
mon idéal en cuisine c'est quoi mon
idéal alors après réflexion un peu grâce
à hâter dicks
j'ai réfléchi et en fait je pense que
mon idéal c'est que quand je cuisine je
puisse vous transmettre la santé
physique et intellectuelle et pour je
puisse vous transmettre cette santé
physique et intellectuelle
je suis obligé de travailler des
produits en forme
quoi des produits en forme alors pour
moi des produits en forme c'est des
produits qu'on profiter de la vie ont
profité de la terre du climat et des
biens sur par des hommes des femmes qui
les ont cultivé en respectant la planète
par exemple les mini légumes
moi ça m'a jamais fait rêver j'ai
l'impression qu'on leur a coupé un peu
la vie des légumes traités à coude
insecticides pesticides chimiques
j'ai l'impression que plutôt que de les
avoir guéris on les a empoisonné donc
moi j'ai l'impression qu'en cuisine en
ces produits je vais aussi vous
empoisonner des produits cultivés en
dehors de la saison alors là c'est
facile à comprendre
là vous vous êtes au mois de juillet
vous êtes à la plage 2 degrés dehors
impossible d'aller se baigner vous êtes
en manteau j'imagine que vous vous
n'auriez pas trop le moral va imaginer
la tomate la fraise en hiver doit pas
avoir trop la forme non plus alors je
parle pas non plus des animaux en
élevage intensif qui sont nés pour
souffrir une vie de cauchemar
comment voulez-vous que moi je puisse
vous transforme vous transmettre la
forme en cultivant ce genre de produits
il ya des producteurs qui n'osent même
plus manger leurs productions qui ne
veulent surtout pas que leurs enfants
fassent le même métier qu'eux qui
tombent malades qui en sont atteints de
cancer et à côté de ça moi je travaille
avec des producteurs qui sont fiers de
leur travail
fiers de leur production qui sont
heureux quand leurs enfants font même
métier qu'eux et qui sont heureux de
voir leurs clients en forme revenir leur
racheter leur production ah c'est sûr
que pour travailler avec ces gens là
j'arrive pas avec ma liste de courses je
m'adapte à leur production
insultez pas non plus une grande femme
d'affaires
mais je ne négocie jamais jamais les
prix je leur fais confiance
on travaille dans le même sens dans le
respect de la planète
certaines fois je trouve même qu'ils
sont pas assez cher et je me permets de
le leur dire à et rigole mais voilà
c'est comme ça
donc le cinquième à gré dian pour
améliorer la condition humaine sur la
planète
vous l'avez compris c'est la nature
notre environnement
le respect de la nature le respect de
l'environnement et donc dans ma recette
de cuisine le cinquième ingrédients bah
oui c'est la pomme de terre
alors là je suis plus dans la variété de
la pomme de terre
je suis dans la vie de la pomme de terre
comment cette pomme de terre a été
cultivé cette pomme de terre si elle
était bien cultivés dans le respect de
l'environnement
elle va vous pouvoir vous transmettre la
forme donc voilà j'ai fini ma recette
mais de recettes
la recette pour améliorer la condition
humaine sur la planète est la recette de
purée de pommes de terre
voilà je suis un chef de cuisine comme
beaucoup de chefs de cuisine on a des
trucs et des astuces et donc j'ai envie
avant de vous quitter de vous faire
partager un truc qui me tient à coeur
voilà quand je réfléchis à mes recettes
de cuisine aussi bien pour le restaurant
que pour mes cours de cuisine que pour
mes livres de cuisine je vais faire
attention à vous mettre en appétit à
vous amener aussi des idées originales
pour ça vous sorte que mes recettes vous
sortent du quotidien à travailler des
produits locaux pour mettre en valeur ma
région mais aussi les hommes de ma
région et aussi surtout je vais chercher
à ce que vous compreniez mes recettes
est-ce que vous ayez envie de cuisiner
mais recettes et pour ça il faut que mes
recettes restent simples monde et la
simplicité et enfin pour conclure j'ai
appris il ya pas très longtemps que des
grands professeurs spécialisés en
nanotechnologies nous précisait nous
prédisent
que nous allons pouvoir vivre très vieux
peut-être jusqu'à milan et bien moi je
ne suis pas du tout scientifique mais je
suis convaincu que la cuisine alors pas
n'importe quel plaisir on est d'accord
la cuisine dont je viens vous parler va
nous permettre aussi de vivre vieux
alors peut-être pas milan mais vivre
vieux mais surtout de vivre heureux
parce que nous allons être obligés de
faire attention à nos ressources
humaines et nos ressources
environnementales
donc voilà il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
souhaiter de bien cuisiner pour que
ensemble nous puissions être heureux et
puis vivre mieux merci